welcome to all of you to the second
session of faith and globalization
seminar and I want to extend special
welcome to our main professor professor
Tony Blair thank you in the last year
when we were when we were doing the same
thing people used to ask me well what's
the relationship of the two of you as
professors and then I said well look
something like this I and his academic
sidekick so it's a pleasant relationship
of being academic sidekick to Prime
Minister Tony Blair today's session
mistakes in faith and globalization and
I think both professor ray and professor
Blair will talk more about this what I
want to do is just to step back a little
bit and then ask the question well what
do you be mean by faith and what do we
mean also by globalization and then to
sketch out for you
some forms of faith engagements with
globalization processes we'll see how
far we can we can get so and the
definitions that I'm going to give you
are what people call stipulative
definition so I'm going to define hung
I'm going to use those terms or how we
are going to roughly use those terms in
this in this course we can debate those
definitions and they will be for debate
as the course continues so first what is
globalization well you can describe
globalization as something like a
planetary process which was historically
driven primarily by interest in trade in
learning about and spreading religion in
Cocke conquest an interest in adventure
and in recent centuries with capitalism
a version of trade is a major force
driving globalization and that's a
planetary process that is leading to
a world of high level of
interconnectivity in which information
goods and services flow increasingly
freely a world not just of
interconnectivity but also of
interdependence with relatively few
independent locales and the world in
which as some scholars say space has
contracted meaning that the whole planet
in a sense has become a new locality and
people who live on that planet are
increasingly becoming this embedded
demurred from particular places
so-called this embedded Cosmopolitan's
and then another feature is that this
globalization produces a consciousness
of the world as a single place we're all
aware that this is what's happening that
we're interconnected that we are
interdependent and that world has shrunk
so what is faith now now I already
mentioned in my first introductory
comments that faith is not kind of or at
least people of faith don't think of
faith as you may have different opinions
about this but people of faith don't
think of faith as a set of irrational
convictions things that you believe
blindly and cannot prove and that's why
it's called faith rather than knowledge
or something like that right or it's not
a mere feeling of awe relating oneself
to some mystery that both repels and
fascinates but rather faith is
convictions and practices of concrete
faith traditions and faith communities
and they have at least the following
functions provide an overarching
interpretation of reality they sketch
how the world is made up fates do they
give an account also of human
flourishing what does it mean to live
well an account that is situated in this
overarching picture of reality
then also thirdly they provide guidance
as to how people should live even feel
and think and act so it's to be in sync
with the reality and so as to flourish
provides guidance for it and provides
also motivation for that now that's what
traditional faiths are doing and the
influence of globalization processes
increasingly we do have especially in
the Western world something what one can
describe and smorgasbord religiosity
catches can really good religiosity
which is basically individual people
maybe with the help of groups pulling
various nuggets of wisdom from various
traditions and creating a usable
religiosity for themselves that too is
religion today now let's look at now
faith and globalization and its
relationship between the two first I
want to sketch briefly globalization's
impact on faith and then I want to look
at faith possible impact on
globalization now some people think that
globalization is inherently secularizing
force good deal of sociologists over the
past three two centuries have thought in
similar terms and there are many people
today who think so as well
now there's also an opposite view which
says that globalization indeed is
nudging people to embrace faith they
maybe feel left behind maybe they feel
uprooted and therefore are in search of
consolation in faith
maybe they sense meaninglessness of
certain ends that they have been
pursuing as a result of being inserted
in the globalization processes in
searching for someone how deeper meaning
in life that also is a possible
relationship of globalization to faith
and globalization is also I think
shaping the form which faith takes fades
get transformed in interaction with
globalization
processes I already spoke about this
smorgasbord religiosity or you have
something like preference and thriving
of world faiths fates that are not tied
to a particular place but that are
easily portable and exportable
Pentecostalism being a very good example
of such a faith and then finally
globalization is shaping the modes of
transmission of faith you have many
faiths who for instance might feel
certain push against globalization
process a globalization using all the
technological means that the
globalization provides in order to
spread that faith whether that's TV
whether that's internet latest
technologies of which I don't know
anything yet they are certainly using in
order to promote faith so globalization
has profound impact upon the world of
faith just as globalization I think has
profound impact on all aspects of our
lives and we'll pick up some of these
themes especially in our session for on
secularization and transformation of
faith to see what's going on with faiths
in the context of contemporary
globalizing world let's me now take a
look at faith stand faith stance toward
globalization so the other aspect of it
in these stances range from on the one
hand denouncing globalization completely
and for today you have read a text that
certainly feels that way that's the
agape text right produced by World
Council of Churches which at least in
the present form completely rejects
globalization as incompatible with some
of the most cherished values of faith
and the other extreme is complete
embracing of globalization some would
argue that globalization process are in
fact realization of some of the ideas
that are embedded in both Judaism
and Christianity about human beings
about freedom of human beings and so
forth there are other the other option
is to disregard globalization processes
empires come and empires go but faith
remains globalization has come
globalization will go but faiths will
remain right so this is part and parcel
of the transitoriness of human existence
over against which way it's stamped and
then finally there's an option or fades
shaping globalization processes we have
you have had as an assignment a text by
Jonathan Sacks dignity of difference
that prologue to that book shows you
some possibilities of engaging
globalization in such a way as to build
a firm and in some ways also shape what
is happening within those processes and
often it's the case that you've got some
religious traditions who have all of
these / did not extensors combined in
one right some aspects of globalization
we want to completely embrace some
aspects we want to completely disregard
deny and disregard others we want to
shape so it's a it's a complex
relationship that fades have to
globalization processes
now I have mentioned very briefly in my
previous remarks I have mentioned about
kind of two strands of engagement
between faith and globalization that
we're going to be pursuing in this
course and you have said in your
readings Jonathan Sacks mentions those
first is fades looking at each other and
examining their own relationship to one
another here the issue is exclusivity of
fades and propensity sometimes of fades
to stabilized closed group identities
which then stand in adversarial
relationships to other identities the
question was how to live in a complex
world where difference drives how to
live in such a way as to affirm as
Jonathan Sacks would put the dignity of
difference so that's a one strand which
we will be looking at mutual
relationships of faith as it plays
itself out under the condition of
globalization processes and then the
second aspect that we will look at is
what faiths might have to say standing
so to say together shoulder to shoulder
and looking at globalization processes
what challenges are there that faiths
face what kinds of contributions can
faiths make to globalization processes
it's one of the things that I have
highlighted is that faiths catch this
overarching interpretation of life and
such overarching interpretation of life
has to somehow fit with the ends that
are being pursued with globalization
processes how these two things fit what
is the conception of human flourishing
that is being carried on the wings of
globalization processes and what is the
conception of human flourishing that
various faiths advocate these two issues
are very significant and I'll end with
this comment those of you who have done
some you've discussed the case study
that we have had
for today was it right on 911 and I'm
not sure whether the I have to remind
myself whether the reading is clear of
that but when we had John Kelsey whose
text you have read here last year as a
resource person it was very clear from
his comments that one ought not to
understand Osama bin Laden's vision has
simply kind of Sparrow respite there is
actually vision of human flourishing a
vision that I don't share particularly
that I'm not very excited about it I
think is detrimental but nonetheless it
is a vision of what it means to live
well as a Muslim particular
understanding of what it means to live
well as Muslim and it's that vision
really that is driving the whole process
I think that is symptomatic about the
engagement of faiths with globalization
processes some are of course more in
tune with the globalization processes
other others are much more posed to
globalization processes in their vision
of human flourishing but that's what
faiths are about and that's where the
intersection happens and I hope that
that's also the place where fruitful
conversation between globalization
process the globalization aid faiths
traditions can take place I think this
is as much as I wouldn't want to say by
the way of introduction and I will now
ask my co professor Douglas Rea just say
a few comments and then professor Blair
will continue